优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive Ja. Tatsächlich hat es bis jetzt bei jeder anderen geregnet. Du bist die einzige, bei der Sonnenschein herrscht. Ist das ein Zeichen? Nee, eigentlich hätte ich es eher andersrum gedacht. Man sieht die überhaupt nicht. Man sieht die, aber es ist so gleich besser. Das ist echt lustig eigentlich. Man sieht immer nur die Haare, man hat immer das Gefühl, man spricht nur mit Haaren eigentlich, was so ein ganz aussergewöhnliches Erlebnis ist.
Wenn man Podcast hört, sieht man auch nur die Haare von den Leuten, die sprechen.
Das stimmt, das ist das Besondere an diesem Medium.
In der Performance, wo ich jetzt gespielt habe, da hat man auch nur meine Haare gesehen, fast mein Gesicht nicht.
Wirklich, wie hast du das hingekriegt, dass man nur deine Haare gesehen hat?
So, ja, das wird man jetzt nicht sehen, aber so.
Okay, sie kämmt sich ihre Haare ans Gesicht, so dass man zwischen Hinterkopf und Vorderkopf nicht mehr unterscheiden kann. Direkt ein ganz anderer Typ. Und was war das für eine Rolle? Ein Menschenhund. Ganz kurz mal eben erstmal. Also, bevor ich denke, was ist hier gerade eigentlich los? Ist es das beste Hörspiel aller Zeiten oder ist wirklich eine Frau da? Ist es wirklich eine Frau da? Viktoria Klimek ist ihr Name, Schauspielerin, wie, Sch würde man nicht am ehesten, äh, würde am ehesten deiner Berufung gerecht werden. Also neben ganz vielen anderen Sachen eigentlich ja doch. Schauspieler, Schauspieler, Superheldin, Sexiest Woman Alive, diese ganzen Sachen halt. Ja, ja. Aber halt auch Schauspielerin. Halt unter anderem, ja. Cool. Und du hast jetzt, also du hast jetzt sehr lange, ähm, in einer, in, quasi in einem Haus gewohnt und hast da eine Performanceart. Crazy shit. Ich habe mal ein neues Lebenskonzept ausprobiert und habe mal in einem Haus gewohnt. Und wie war das so? Krass. Wie viele Wände, wofür hast du dich entschieden? Ich habe mich, das war ja ganz verschachtelt, das war ja ein Schuhkarton-Haus. Ach was. Ja, also nicht nur ein Haus, sondern auch ein Haus mit mehreren Stockwerken und Räumen und Schuhschachteln.
Da habe ich gewohnt und gearbeitet und gebellt und geknurrt und gebissen.
Und du warst ein Menschenhund?
Ein sogenannter, ich kenne den Fachbegriff zufällig, ein Möter, halb Mensch, halb Köter.
Nein, Hunsch.
Ach, Hunsch. Ich kenne es als Möter.
Ja, das Hundschmieds Möter wäre bestimmt auch eine schöne.
Wo ist der Unterschied? Hast du dich da tief in die Rolle eingelebt, wie hast du es gemacht, wie hast du den Kern der Rolle gefunden? Ja, den Hund in mir gesucht, dass ich einfach den Impulsen nachgegangen bin, jeden, den ich scheisse finde, zu beissen. Das geht relativ schnell. Auch Bällen als Kommunikationsmittel erspart einem manche Diskussion.
Autos nachlaufen.
Autos, Tauben jagen.
Eichhörnchen. Auch Bällen als Kommunikationsmittel erspart einem manche Diskussion. Autos nachlaufen. Autos, Tauben jagen, herumtollen, auf Rünen wiesen, Zeitungen bringen, endlich mal alles auf allen Vieren machen. Aber ganz kurz, also welcher Teil von dir war Hund, welcher Teil war Mensch? Oder wie war es eine Meerjungfrau, dass dein Hinterteil alles fällig war? Der Körper war ja Mensch, also ganz assimilieren konnte ich nicht. Die Beweglichkeit, die Körperlichkeit war hündisch und die Seele war natürlich Hund. Der Geist und die Seele. Okay, cool. Ist es denn einfacher oder schwerer, verschiedene Emotionen mit Bällen oder mit Menschen die Sprache darzustellen? Was ist näher dran? Da einen sehr aggressiven Hunch gespielt habe, war es sehr einfach, mit Bällen Sachen zu klären und das färbt auch auf meinen Alltag ab. Aber ich glaube, wenn es vielleicht, wenn man dann doch mal irgendwann vielleicht was Nettes sagen will, die zarten Töne fallen ein wenig schwerer. Da muss man ins Winseln umsteigen, ins Schnurren. Ja, genau, so ein Schnurgeräusch, Fiepsen. Aber angenommen, du würdest das Licht anhaben wollen in diesem Raum, es ist gerade sehr dunkel, wie würdest du das als Hunch versuchen, uns jetzt deutlich zu machen, dass so was nicht bitte angemacht werden soll? Ich konnte ja auch ein bisschen sprechen, aber ich versuch's mal hündisch. Huch, Licht! Nee. Licht! Och Gott, oh Gott. Ein bisschen, ja. Holy shit, das war jetzt eher so ein bisschen ein Mensch als Dämon einfach, aber auch nicht schlecht. Ja, aber es hatte auch was Dämonisches, ich hatte auch einen Wolfspelz an und. Alter, das ist ganz schön heftig. Ich wusste vorher nicht, dass man Hornhaut an den Knien entwickeln kann. Kann man? Wirklich? Kann man, ja. So richtige Hornhaut? Ja, also ein bisschen, also so von der Textur ein bisschen anders, als das, was man an den Füssen hat, aber doch, also es ist, ich kann auch feilen, ohne dass es weh tut. Ich glaube, man kann potenziell überall Hornhaut entwickeln, oder? Ja, aber man hat vielleicht sonst nicht drei Monate Zeit, um diesen Körperteil so lange immer auf dem Boden zu schubbern. Ja, das stimmt. Oder möchte das vielleicht auch nicht. Könntest du Farben sehen? Oder hast du irgendwann aufgehört, Farben zu sehen? Nee, ich habe Farben gesehen. Du hast Farben weiterhin gesehen. Ja, ja. Welche Farben hast du mir? Das ist ja gefährlich, wenn du einenben hast du gesehen? Du kommst ja nicht mehr raus. Wenn du zu lange einen Hund spielst, kannst du nicht mehr Farben sehen. Das ist die Regel. Das steht bei Wikipedia. Ja. Falschem Wikipedia, bin ich ja weiss, Wikipedia.bits oder so. Die Doggypedia. Method acting gone wrong. Ja. Aber, äh, äh, Farben sehen, welche Farben, unser Set war rosa hauptsächlich. Cool. Vielleicht hast du es in der Recherche von deiner Rolle schon erfahren, aber es gibt ja einen alten Klassiker, den ich noch mal abstauben möchte, Dog-TV. Es gibt ja Fernsehen, das extra für Hunde gemacht wurde. Hast du da mal reingeschaut, mal reingesappt oder die besten Bits irgendwie von deinen Kollegen dann? In der Recherche habe ich das tatsächlich ein-, zweimal gemacht. In der Fiktion hatten wir Teleshopping, den ganzen Tag laufen. Das war Teil unseres Sets, das heisst, ich bin jetzt eigentlich eher so ein QVC-Pro. Also es ist auch, da ich ja jeden Abend gespielt habe, weiss ich auch ganz genau, welche Sendung wann, was, wie. Also mich dann eher da weitergegeben. Wie viel Mitspracherecht hat man bei so einem Kunstprojekt?
Also kannst du dann, war das auch von dir mitorganisiert? Ja, ich habe schon überlegt, was sieht einfach geil absurd aus und habe mir dann da auch, dann schon auch Teleshopping gewünscht. Okay, gut. Und was war das Kunstprojekt jetzt an sich? Ihr habt den ganzen Tag Teleshopping geschaut und so getan, als wärt ihr ein Hund, oder was? Ja, unterm Strich kann man das auch so nennen, das war fürs Volkstheater in Wien, jetzt im Rahmen der Wiener Festwochen so eine Performance-Installation. Das heißt also, wie lange dauert das dann? Fünf Stunden am Abend haben wir gespielt. Jeden Abend fünf Stunden lang? Ja, wir hatten ab und zu mal unregelmäßig auch zwei Tage frei. Aber Installation heißt, da wird es nicht so etwas wie eine Geschichte erzählt oder so etwas, sondern es ist einfach nur eine Szenerie oder nur so. Nee, nee, nee, das ist aber ... Installation heisst, du dich so lange auch weiter, bis es installiert ist. Da gehst du durch und dann rede ich aber auch mit dir. Oder auch Leute, die Menschen spielen, sprechen auch mit dir, du bist Teil der Geschichte. Es gibt eine Story schon, es ist jetzt nicht so ein LARP-mässiges Ding, es gibt keinen Quest oder so, aber du gehst da durch und du erlebst was. Danke, dass du für mich, wenn du mit mir redest, direkt die ganzen Jungfrauen-Nerd-Bekriffe benutzt hast. Ich hab's verstanden so. Ich weiss, was ein Lab ist. Es ist nicht wie bei WoW, wenn ein Org, ein Murlock kommt. Ich habe mit sehr vielen Leuten jetzt gesprochen, ich bin jetzt schon auch sehr empathisch geworden. Ich weiss, was eine Quest ist, ich weiss, was ein Murlock ist. Ich bin total dabei, du hast es genau richtig erklärt. Ja, geil. Und was war denn, was war das Bigger Picture? Also Kunst soll ja auch was vermitteln.
Nein, also es geht um Erleben einer bestimmten Fiktion.
Okay, aber welche Gefühle soll man erleben? Was soll man Verwunderung?
Wenn Menschen sich verhalten wie Hunde und es andere Menschen gibt, die deren Herrchen spielen, ist es glaube ich so ein Machtgefälle, ja, offensichtlich dann schnell, wenn man da durchgeht, dass das eben, und es geht viel um Würde. Das heißt, die Zuschauer konnten dich dann auch umbefehlen und dir dann, die haben eine Zeitung auf dem Kopf hauen. Nee, die nicht, ich hatte ja ein Herrchen, das war der einzige, auf den ich hören musste, aber die Zuschauer haben es natürlich versucht, es gibt auch Leute, die kommen rein, sehen dich eine Minute als Hund und stecken ihre ganze Hand in den Mund. Man merkt schon, wie krank die Menschen auch sind, wenn man denen den Raum dafür gibt. Ja gut, aber da geht man ja relativ schnell ins Grenzen austesten, oder? Ja. Wenn du das heisst, irgendwie, aber gibt es dann auch... Ich habe richtige Fight-Namen, kann ich euch mal zeigen hier. Oben, ne, muss ich andersrum zeigen. Wow! Ach du Schande. Ach du Schande. Also, du wurdest auch gebissen von anderen Hunden oder von Zuschauern? Ja, von anderen Hunden. Von Kindern. Von echten Hunden, die plötzlich kamen so, Moment mal Leute hier. Ganz kurz, das ist mein Gebi. Äh, was soll der Scheiss gerade? Hat nur ein Hund mitgemacht. Ach so, aber, ähm, also gab's dann auch, gibt's dann auch Momente, wo man dann kurz aus der Rolle fällt oder sagt so irgendwie, was soll das jetzt irgendwie, wenn dann wirklich jemand übergriffig wird oder sowas oder ist sowas, passiert sowas nicht. Oder wenn jemand eine Serie spoilert und man ganz gut sagt, Leute, irgendwo hat der Spaß auch mal auf. Ich konnte halt mal beissen. Genau, man muss zuhören, ja. Du glaubst nicht, was John Snow gesagt hat, aah! Ah, okay, sorry, kurz und so ist alles cool, aber fick dich, Game of Thrones. Das wäre ein klassischer Bärmoment gewesen. Ich bin eigentlich ein Hund, aber ganz kurz, halt die Fresse, halt die Fresse!
So ganz seltsame, wo ganz seltsame Punkten aus der Rolle fallen. Aber kommen dann auch viele Leute, die es nicht ernst nehmen und irgendwie rumalbern oder euch aus der Rolle bringen wollen, die dann irgendwie so den London Guards irgendwie dann irgendwie versuchen, aus dem Konzept zu bringen oder so? Ja, das gibt's schon, aber ziemlich schnell, dadurch, dass es ja auch ein sehr langer Zeitraum ist, in dem das stattfindet, merken die Leute, dass die sich ja selber nur was nehmen, wenn die die
ganze Zeit sich überhaupt nicht mit dem beschäftigen, was sie da sehen, sondern eigentlich nur mit sich selber und ihrer eigenen Show. Also die meisten kriegt man schon irgendwann ein wenig dem, was zu geben. Also du musst verstehen, dass wir normalen Menschen mit einem normalen Leben überhaupt gar nicht in diese Kunstwelt klarkommen und verstehen, was das alles soll und was es ist. Nein, das ist aber auch, mein Leben ist ja auch normalerweise nicht so. Ich war jetzt drei Monate einfach so ein bisschen im Weltall und jetzt bin ich gerade in Köln wieder angekommen. Klar ist das für mich jetzt gerade normal, aber ich weiss schon, dass das sehr merkwürdig ist. Und es gab auch in meinem Leben wenig andere Momente, in denen ich mich so seltsam gefühlt habe, wie in einem Wolfspelz und Unterwäsche mit einem Knochen im Mund in einer Bahn zu sitzen und das durchzuziehen. Ach, dann auch im öffentlichen Raum? Auch im öffentlichen Raum, ja. Es sind bestimmt YouTube-Videos von dir. Es mag sein, ja. Ich weiß noch nicht, unter welchem... Wird es bestimmt oft gefilmt, oder? So oft war ich ja nicht draußen. Es war zweimal, haben wir Leute getroffen und sonst im Haus. Nö, da durften sie sich da nicht. Interessant ist ja die Frage, du wurdest oft gefilmt, oder, aufgeschrieben hast, nachdem sie gesagt hat, dass sie in Unterwäsche war. Ja, klar, natürlich. Komisch, dass du genau darauf zurückgekommen bist jetzt. Ja, ich frage mich immer, wo diese nächsten Videos landen dann, wenn man irgendwie so was Verrücktes auf der Strasse sieht. Aber sie hat auch gesagt Wolfspelz, ich habe mir die Premiere in Wolfspelz vorgestellt. Ja, es ist eine aufregende Mischung. Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen. Aber es war ein echter Wolfspelz? Ich weiß nicht, ich habe das behauptet. Mensch im Wolfspelz. Aber es war ein echter Pelz, das schon. Mensch im Wolfspelz, ja das hat was. Besser als Pelz im Wolfspelz. Ich war noch nie zur Sprache, das ist glaube ich nach einer Geschichte einfach, weil das so ja ist verrückt, das ist wirklich aus meiner Lebensredakte. Aber das ist echt abgefahren, cool. Aber hast du noch andere Projekte gemacht, die ehemals irgendwann so crazy waren? Weil das ist schon wirklich heftig. Also das ist jetzt schon das Verrückteste gewesen. Okay, cool. Gott sei Dank. Ansonsten nur Telenovelas einfach den ganzen Tag. Genau, genau, das finde ich schon am schönsten. Aber Comedy ist auch so ein bisschen, ich meine, wir machen ja hier, wir sagen immer Comedy-Podcasts ein bisschen lächerlich, aber wir versuchen es dann doch, aber hast du auch Interesse und Bock drauf, ne? Ich habe schon Interesse am lustig sein, ja. Hast du schon mal Stand-up gemacht? Nee. Das ist jetzt so gerade, ich war gerade im, im, im, im dabei, das aufzubauen und also ich schreibe schon länger eigene Texte und habe es auch so ein bisschen, habe ich schon mal gemacht, Stand-Up aber nichts, was man jetzt irgendwie, womit ich jetzt mich schmücken könnte. Und war Anfang des Jahres in Berlin und hab da relativ eng auch mit ein, zwei Leuten zusammengearbeitet und so. Und dann kam dieser Gaga-Auftrag und dann fand ich das geil und hab das gemacht. Stand-Up oder Hund sein und in die Wohnung scheissen? Hm. Das ich nicht gemacht. Okay. Und wie lange hast du das gemacht, die Hundennummer? Wir haben geprobt seit März und Premiere war Mitte Mai und bis gestern war ich da. Okay, also wie lang? Drei Monate ja. Okay, also in Hundemonaten? Acht Jahre. Ja, ich bin ja ein Hundsch, da bin ich genauso alt wie ihm. Aber Hund, aber Hunsch wäre ja dann mal drei, mal fünf wahrscheinlich. Hund ist ja mal sieben, richtig? Nee, Hunsch ist Mensch, ist Hund. Ein Menschenjahr sind sieben Hundejahre. Ich weiss das gar nicht, ich mag Hunde nicht. Welchen Hunsch würdest du gerne mal spielen? So Pfundsch, halb Pfirsich, halb Mensch oder was, wo würdest du gerne noch mal reingehen? Das Stück, wo wir gespielt haben, das hieß ja Wir Hunde und ich wäre total interessiert entweder an Wir Pferde oder Wir Kaninchen, das schnellste Stück der Welt, oder aber fände auch Wir Vögel ganz schön, weil das kann man einfach nur einmal machen. Wir Vögel? Warte, weil dann alle wegfliegen oder was? Nee, weil Halb Mensch, Halb Vogel scheitert in dem Moment daran, dass wir einfach nie werden fliegen können. Ach so, ein sehr deprimierendes Stück. Das kann eine Geschichte weniger von Macht als eine Geschichte vom Scheitern sein. Ja, das wäre, ja, wir Vögel wären ganz, ganz, das wäre auch wieder mit viel Herz dabei, ich fände es aber auch sehr lustig. Ich stelle mir die Person, die sich ein Theaterstück anschaut, das Wunsch heisst und dann lauter Halbwurm, Halbwurm, Halbmenschen dann auch umkreuchen. Damit hat er nicht gerechnet. Ja. Kann passieren. Das Stück hieß ja Wir Hunde, Us Dogs. Ein älterer Herr hat mich dann auf der Hälfte der Zeit gefragt, warum das Stück denn US Dogs heisst und wo jetzt in der Military-Kontext geht. US Dogs, Tough Men. Ich wollte kurz den Gag machen, man könnte auch Mensch sagen, ein Mensch, halb Mad-Eagle, halb Mensch. Oder halb Mandarine, halb Mensch, manch.
Aber das wäre nicht, vielleicht manch und nicht mensch. Aber gut, lassen wir es.
Gestern war jemand hier, sie hat sehr lange eine Taube gespielt und heute hat sehr lange jemand, der einen Hund gespielt hat.
Ich finde es ein bisschen seltsam, gerade in welche Richtung des Podcasts.
Gut, dass ihr euch beiden nicht getroffen habt, sonst wäre es da glaube ich gleich zu einem Kampf gekommen.
Ja, das wäre aber auch private Katastrophe.
Also bei Wir Vögel könnte ich eigentlich, würde ich es wahrscheinlich nicht machen können, weil ich so eine Phobie habe. Du hast eine Vogelphobie? Du hast eine FF, eine Vogelphobie? Ach krass. Wie drückt sich das aus? Beides mal falsch, richtig gut. Ich kann nicht essen und nicht trinken, wenn Vögel in der Nähe sind. Aber hast du denn auch so einen Vogelsensor, also dass du immer weisst, wenn Vögel in der Nähe sind?
Ja. Ich kann nicht essen und nicht trinken, wenn Vögel in der Nähe sind. Aber hast du denn auch so einen Vogelsensor, also dass du immer weißt, wenn Vögel in der Nähe sind? Ja, das ist auch zum Beispiel, wenn wir jetzt einen Kaffee trinken gehen würden und dann würden wir in so einem netten Strassencafé sitzen und vor uns hat jemand da ein Panino. Ja, ich hätte Zeit. Ja, machen wir doch danach, dann wirst du es auch direkt sehen. Dann hätte wohl vorher jemand ein Panino oder sowas gegessen, was so ein bisschen bröselt. Panino? Ich würde ja zum Beispiel nie draußen ein Stück Kuchen oder etwas ankommen. Das ist das Erste, was dir einfällt zu essen, ist ein Panino. Ich weiss nicht mal, was ein Panino ist, ehrlich gesagt. Weil wir würden doch in so einen netten, so einen Fernsehladen gehen. Was ist denn ein Panino? Das ist ein italienisch anmutend belegtes Antipasti, heisst das nicht als Singular Panino? Das ist die alte Frage, ob ein Spagett ... Ein Spaghetto. Ein Spaghetto, ein Spaghetti, Spaghetto, Panino. Ich gebe dir den Punkt. Ja. Und dann, also wenn ein Vogel in der Nähe ist, dann könntest du, dann würdest du ein Panini ... Ich merke dann in meinem peripheren Blickfeld, egal, wir würden uns ja unglaublich gut unterhalten, aber trotzdem würde ich sehen, ah, da ist so, sagen wir so 20 Meter so eine Taube, ich bin dann erstmal, noch nicht beunruhigt, aber wachsam. Und wenn sie näher kommt, könnte es sein, dass du dann denkst, vielleicht ist sie auch übergeschnappt, weil dann passiert schon mal sowas. Ja, du trittst sie da weg? Ja, ich berühre sie dann ja nicht, weil darum geht es ja, aber dass sie Angst kriegen. Aber das ist interessant. Man mag ja oft an anderen Menschen und Wesen das nicht, was man an sich selber nicht mag. Und ich glaube, wenn du sehr wachsam bist, ist es vielleicht das, was dich stört, weil die Vögel sind auch sehr wachsam. Tauben. Klar, Tauben sind immer auf Zack. Nee, aber wenn da richtig viel Panino rumliegt, dann sind die so unwachsam, dann kannst du wirklich, dann musst du in die reintreten. Aber woher zur Hölle kommt denn eine Vogelphobie? Ja, habe ich meine Eltern auch schon gefragt. Und die haben gesagt, go, go oder was haben die gesagt? Die haben gesagt, dass ich auch schon als Kleinkind im Kinderwagen angefangen habe zu heulen, wenn irgendwo Vögel in der Nähe waren. Das ist echt interessant. Haben wir das nicht mal erzählt? Auf jeden Fall ist es so, wenn du einem Therapeuten sagst, dass du Angst vor Vögeln hast oder geträumt hast, ein Albtraum war das mit Vögeln, dann hast du massive Probleme im Bett. Das ist kein Scherz. Das ist wirklich kein Scherz. Das ist wirklich so. Moment, mit Bett meinst du jetzt Sex oder was? Bei Vögeln oder was? Aber dann war ja mein Stück weit schon vorprogrammiert. Aber das glaube ich nicht. Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Aber nur wegen Vögeln jetzt? Nein, nein, nein, Nein, nein, nein, das ist ja keine Vögelfobie. Nee, richtig, genau. Das ist der Gag, den ich auch erst vermutet hatte in dem Gespräch mit demjenigen. Mit Sigmund Freud. Aber ich glaube, kein ernsthafter Psychologe würde sagen, dass es eine klare, da die Zuhörungen gibt, Vögel in deinem Traum heisst sowas. Aber das wäre dann wirklich dramatisch, wo wir jetzt eben auch gesagt haben, wir Vögel wären so ein Stück vom Scheitern. Dann wäre ich ja von Anfang an born to scheitern, wenn ich schon mit anderthalb Jahren geweint habe vor Vögeln. Das heißt, man konnte ja dann auf meine Psyche gar keinen Einfluss nehmen. Sexuell konnte ich mich gar nicht, konnte ja gar nichts. Ich hatte von Anfang an schlechte Karten fürs Bett. Du, wir leben in einer Zeit, wo man das ganz einfach nachlesen kann, woher eine Vogelfobie kommt. Ich lese euch kurz allein in eurem Gespräch, ich lese es kurz nach. Ja, es gibt einen guten Film von Alfredischer Hitchcock, den kann ich dir empfehlen. Ja, genau so unmöglich wie nach Venedig zu fahren. Venedig geht gar nicht? Ja, ich würde es machen, aber die Outskirts dann, ne? Okay, dann eher so in den Ghettos, in den Slums. Oder auf dem Wasser, so hätte ich auch. Wasser, ja, mit den Fischen, ist das dann eher was für dich? Fisch ist voll okay, kein Problem. Ich bin in Afrika aufgewachsen, ich habe immer viel mit Fischen. Aber was, also kannst du es festmachen, gibt's also, sind Flügeltiere per se ein Problem? Also jetzt ein Huhn zum Beispiel, ist ein Huhn dann auch schon, bringt da dein Vogelsensor schon an? Wenn's tot ist, nicht. Okay, aber jetzt sagen wir was mit Flügeln, das aber jetzt, also ein Flugzeug zum Beispiel, ist das schon ein Problem? Flugzeug, ne das geht. Flugzeug ist okay. Ist es der Schnabel, ein Schnabeltier? Es ist diese Textur, diese Oberfläche mit diesen Federn drauf, das, was so ein bisschen gewabert. Ah, es sind die Federn. So dieser komische Körper. Ich finde das richtig ekelhaft. Es sind weder der Schnabel und die Füsse, was viele auch haben, meiner Leidensgenossen, man findet sich ja dann als Neurotiker, dass die meisten finden Schnabel und Füsse, ja.
Ich habe jetzt ein Bild von einer Taube in die Richtung.
Stefan, will sie erschrecken, das ist die Konfrontationstherapie.
So, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wie das Gespräch weitergeht.
Aber erinnert sich mein Gesicht schon?
Aber ich glaube, ich weiss, was du meinst, weil Vögel haben ja so einen recht leicht
gebauten, so einen aerodynamischen, knöchernen Körper, ne, das ist so ein bisschen, ja,
es ist so recht leicht und fast wohl. Magst du Dinosaurier? Jetzt können wir das Rätsel lösen! Ja. Also hat ein Dinosaurier keine Flügel. Dinosaurier sind angeblich die direkten Vorfahren von Vögeln. Wenn du sagst, wenn du sagst, na ja, denn du sagst, du hast keine Angst vor Dinosauriern, aber Angst vor Vögeln, glaube ich, haben wir gerade die Wissenschaft umgeschrieben. Denn ganz offensichtlich haben die Dinosaurier dann nichts mit Vögeln zu tun. Die offene Frage ist, ob Dinosaurier Federn hatten, ja oder nein. Nein, aber wenn sie Federn hatten, dann wirst du es nicht tun. Vielen Dank für deine Meinung, aber da streiten sich Wissenschaftler halt darum, ob die jetzt Federn hatten oder nicht. Nein, nein, ich wollte jetzt nicht hier den Wissenschaftler-Schauspieler-Meinung eingreifen, aber ich habe ja gerade die Frage beantwortet, ob ich sie mag. Das heisst, ich muss ja auf ein Bild eingehen, was ich ja von einem Dinosaurier habe. Aber das war so ein bisschen der Gag an der Sache, ja, das stimmt. Ja, habe ich den. Aber gut, ist kein Problem. Aber was sehr lustig ist, hier ist, wenn man von der einen BTF zu anderen BTF geht, der Arbeitgeber, für den wir beide arbeiten, was im Namen Arbeitgeber schon nicht drin ist, dann muss man aus einer Eisenbahnbrücke druntergehen. Und da drin nisten oben Milliarden Tauben ungefähr. Das heißt, wenn man drunter hergeht, das ist halt der ganze Boden ist schon ein Haufen Vogelschiss, ein grosser Taubenschiss. Das heißt, ich habe keine Angst vor Vögeln und finde die auch eigentlich ziemlich cool, ich finde Vögel echt sehr interessant, auch ihre Fähigkeiten, aber das ist wirklich mega widerlich, was du da durchmachen musst, für jeden, auch wenn du nicht ornithophob bist, aber das ist wirklich heftig.
Und hast du mal über eine Superheldenkarriere nachgedacht, also so Bird Woman oder so, dass du dann halt offensiv mit deinen Phobien umgehst?
Ne, ich habe über Konfrontationstherapie nachgedacht, ich habe gedacht, vielleicht mache ich mal so ein Praktikum in so einem Vogelpark oder so. Oder setze mich dem mal länger aus. Aber wer weiß, wenn ich jetzt diese Stand-up-Geschichte mal antreibe, wenn ich dann mal ein Federnkostüm oder... Der erste Vogel-Stand-up. Das ist eine Nische vielleicht. Verdi-Klimmec oder so. Ja, oder auf deiner Hochzeit irgendwie so tausend weisse Tauben oder so was in der Richtung. Die Vogelhochzeit. Die Vogelhochzeit nachspielen. Je nachdem, ja. Aber eigentlich, ich glaube, man kommt ganz gut ohne Vögel aus in seinem Leben. Die sind relativ einfach zu umgehen. Ja, also ich schaffe mir auch meine Freiräume. Als Neurotiker hast du ja deine Muster, wie du bestimmten Dingen ausweichst. Papagei? Papagei ist ganz cool, ja. Kakadu? Tukan? Das war mein erstes Haustier. Aha! Da haben wir doch. In welchem Alter? Und der war fies bestimmt. Sieben. Das war schon nach der Fug. Ist der gestorben? Das war schon nachdem ich schon vor der Fug war. Was war der Trauma? Aber der war auch immer im Käfig, ne? Ich musste den, ich durfte den, also ich musste den ja auch nicht berühren, ne? Und der war witzig, weil der hat mich am allermeisten nachgemacht. Er hat einen Joke erzählt. Hat er dich nachgemacht? Oder du ihn nachgemacht? Ja, das hat meine Eltern ziemlich kirre gemacht, weil die dauernd dachten, wenn ich... Ich hab Angst vor Vögeln, huuuhuuhuuhu. Ja, oder wenn ich nicht da war, hat er dann Spirenze mit denen, hat er dann irgendwie so einen unterschiedlichen Lautstärken Mama gerufen. Und meine Mutter dachte immer, wo ist sie denn, wo kommt sie denn jetzt wieder her? Was für ein Arschloch, Alter, wie geil ist das denn? Mama, ich ertrinke, Mama, ich ertrinke! Scheiss Papagei wieder. Dann lacht er einfach. Aber das ist geil. Aber vor allem, das habe ich mich auch gefragt, wenn Papageien wehen nachmachen, und dann sagt man das irgendwann nochmal, was der Papagei immer sagt, wer macht dann wehen nach eigentlich? Wer ist dann derjenige, der die wehen nachmacht. Ich glaube, damit kannst du Papageien richtig fertig machen, wenn du ein Papagei nachmachst. Ich glaube, da schien die komplett einfach so, töte mich, töte mich. Oder halt zwei Papageien in einem Käfig, ich glaube, die haben genug zu tun erstmal. So ein Endlosschleife, wie man zwei Furbies gegenüber neunerangestellt. Ja, nur mal, zeitweise eine Besuchspapagei. Dann war er aber relativ still, glaube ich. Wie Versuchspapagei. Besuchspapagei. Ach, Besuchspapagei. Die verbinden sich dann irgendwie mit Bluetooth und dann ist es okay. Genau. Ja, das ist alles cool. Ich habe mal gehört, dass jemand, er hatte zwei Vögel und dann ist einer gestorben, und damit der andere Vogel nicht so einsam ist, haben die dann einfach so einen Tennisball mit zwei Federn drin in den Käffi gelegt. Und. Und ich dachte auch, cool, dass ihr euch Sorgen um euren trauernden Vogel macht, aber haltet den auch nicht für komplett behindert. Aber das wäre dann vielleicht eine Idee für mich. Ja, so ein Tennisball mit ... Mit Federn erstmal, um mich da dran an die Materie zu gewöhnen. Ja. Also so ein grosser, so ein sehr Medizinball, einfach mit Federn dran. Ja, fangen wir erst mal mit dem Tennisball an und dann steigern wir uns mal. Oder mit Angry Birds Highscore oder sowas, da langsam hoch. Ja, ja, Angry Birds mag ich auch nicht so, aber das … Ich hatte auch mal, ich bin so Wellensittige zwei, und dann ist der eine gestorben und dann habe ich den anderen, weil ich den nicht alleine haben wollte, die auch loswerden wollte, diese scheiß Viecher, wollte ich dann … Ich wollte die loshaben. Da habe ich den einen dann, der noch über war, ausgesetzt. Nee, da habe ich eine Zoohandlung gegeben zu anderen. Und dann habe ich mir gedacht, irgendwer hat dann, der war auch schon vier Jahre alt, und die werden auch nicht so alt, das heißt, der war schon sehr kurz vor seinem Lebensende, irgendwer hat einfach einen Vogel gekauft, dachte, er wird mit dem alt und so, und der war einfach schon uralt, so um die achtzig in den Menschenjahren, der einfach bestimmt innerhalb der nächsten Woche gestorben ist. Ich habe schon alles gesehen, mein Junge. Der Mensch hat jetzt wahrscheinlich noch ... Auch eine Vogelphobie. Ja, oder ... Du vielleicht sogar. Eine Fofo, eine Vogelphobie ist auch nicht schlecht. Ja, FF-Fofo. FF war besser. Ja, stimmt. Wie du dann nach einer halben Stunde eine schlechtere ... Ich habe ihn gerade vergessen, jetzt alles ich schon gehört habe. Scheiße, naja, jetzt leiden wir raus. Ja, vor allem dieser Mensch denkt, er hat einfach kein Händchen für Tiere. Ja, das muss sein. Das ist schon eine Ornithobie. Ornithobie. Ornithobie. Ja. Krass. Also wir haben jetzt Hund-Thema komplett abgearbeitet, würde ich sagen. Vogel auch. Also was beschäftigt die Tanzäunde im Leben? Es ist verrückt, wenn Menschen so genau wissen, wovor sie Angst haben. Man hat ja vor verschiedenen Sachen Angst, aber man kann das gar nicht so festmachen. Das ist vielleicht eigentlich auch ganz geil, dass man genau weiss, vor Vögeln habe ich Angst, aber der Rest ist mir scheiss egal, da kann ich alles machen. Würmer, Seesterne, Quallen, überhaupt kein Problem. Und bei normalen Menschen ist es eher so, ja, manche Tiere mag ich, manche nicht so, bei denen mag ich das nicht, aber du weisst ganz genau, wovor du Angst hast. Vielleicht bist du insgesamt die furchtlosere Person, weil du genau festlegen kannst, wovor du Angst hast.
Ja, weil ich muss mich ja nicht darum mehr kümmern, das weiss ich ja schon, dass ich da Angst habe.
Und da kannst du auch aktiv dagegen angehen, wohingegen ich dir jetzt irgendwie, ich habe Angst vor einem Leoparden, aber nicht vor einem Luchs, what the fuck ist da los?
Wahrscheinlich stirbst du an einem Luchsangriff, an einem grossen Luchsangriff 2019, wohingegen der grosse Vogelangriff, die grosse Vogelgrippewelle vielleicht, die die Weltmenschheit auslöst, wird dir nichts anhaben, weil du dich...
Ich Einen grossen Luchsangriff 2019, wohingegen der grosse Vogelangriff, die grosse Vogelgrippe, die die Weltmenschheit auslöst, wird dir nichts anhaben, weil du dich… Weil ich mich so fernhalte von Vögeln.
Ja, vielleicht ist es dein Schicksal, Angst vor Vögeln zu haben, damit du überlebst. Du bist die eine. Mit dem Wissen.
Ja, je nachdem, wie gross der Vogelangriff wird. Wenn der Luchsangriff kommt und ich einfach keine Angst habe, dann sind wir einfach beide für den Luchs.
Oder so Lüchse, die auf Füchsen reiten. Sorry, auf Fügeln reiten. Flux. Flux-Kontau-Bensator. Alles klar, ich bin raus, macht's gut, ciao! Du wolltest mich gerade was fragen, weil ich bei mir so viel über Tiere bin. Ja, ich wollte einfach in eine andere Richtung, ich weiß auch nicht, in welche Richtung das gegangen ist. Ja, es ist so sehr viel Farm und ich mag zum Beispiel auch eigentlich nicht so, ich bin gar nicht so ein grosser Tierfreund. Was treibt dich so um? Also, wir haben gesehen, du bist in Lagos geboren worden. Ja. Was ist das denn? Wow, was ist da die Geschichte dahinter? Lagos. Ja, mein Vater hat da gearbeitet, er hat Sprengstoff verkauft. Oh Gott, er hat Landminien ausgesinnt. Gut, ich cancel alle meine Termine heute, lass uns über deinen Vater reden. Sprengstoff an wen? Ja, jetzt wird es langweilig, an die Regierung und an diverse Baufirmen für infrastrukturelle Massnahmen in Nigeria. Ja, ja. Was haben wir so in die Luft gesprungent? Infrastrukturelle Maßnahmen oder soll ich lieber sagen, Mordnamen, wird kein Schuh draus, aber bist du sicher, dass es alles … Ich dachte jetzt, Marsnamen. Marsnamen. Wir mussten zum Beispiel auch mal drei Tage das Haus verlassen, weil man uns unterstellt hat, wir würden Waffen schmuggeln und so. Ja, das sind so die … oder wo ein schul-sicheren Auto aus dem Land gebracht werden, das sind so die creepy Highlights meiner Kindheit. Kennst du dich denn auch ein bisschen mit Sprengstoff aus, wenn dein Vater da Experte war? Leider nicht, leider nicht. Das ärgert mich auch extrem, weil ich bin da auch ein bisschen pyromanisch unterwegs. Und das Lager, wo der Sprengstoff gelagert wurde, war aber nicht in Lagos selber, sondern so 300 Kilometer oder so entfernt. Und irgendwie fanden meine Eltern das gar nicht mal so cool, mit dem Kind da hinzufahren. Aber finde ich, wenn irgendwo ein Lager sein sollte, dann in Lagos. Dein Vater ist aber schon Deutscher, oder? Ja. Okay, also das heißt, du bist nur in Lagos geboren worden, aber hast nicht da gelebt lange? Doch, zehn Jahre. Ach, zehn Jahre lang. Zehn Jahre. Bis da alles weggebombt hat einfach und dann... Das heißt,st fliessend... Afrikanisch. Ja, Lagi. Lagi. Du sprichst afrikanisch tatsächlich? Nein, ich spreche einfach... Ich bin bilingual, deutsch, englisch aufgewachsen, aber das ist ja nicht so fancy. Nee, denkt ihr vielleicht da eine bessere Geschichte aus? Ja. Viktoria, räum mal deine Lagos weg. So was kann niemand checken. Ja. Wir haben gestern überlegt, ähm … Ist ja nur ein sehr einsames Leben. Lagosland, hätte man sagen. Lagosland, ja. Ach, damn it! Sorry, ey, ihr kommt immer 30 Sekunden zu spät. Lagosien. Ich schneide die jetzt davor, damit haben wir einen guten Gangflow. Ja, danke. Okay, hast du schon mal ein Tier getötet, weil du meinst, du bist nicht so tierlieb? Also, was war das grösste Tier, das du jemals getötet hast? Ähm, ich habe einen Vogel überfahren. So, mit deinem Kinderwagen? Voller Absicht, hast du euch die Gasse gegeben, ne? Schönen scheiß Vogel. Nee, mit einem Fowel-Lupo. Oh, okay. War mit ein bisschen Absicht dabei, nenn mich an? Äh, nur ein toter Vogel ist ein guter Vogel. Hm, was war es denn für ein Vogel? Taube. Die schlimmsten. Ja, nee, ich habe es wirklich genossen, dann war sie ja eh schon tot, bin ja nochmal rückwärts. Rück Aber wie hast du das denn geschafft? Das ist doch gar nicht so einfach, heul. Ja eben, ich fahr so lange schon Auto. Das war ein Highlight meiner Autofahrerkarriere, dass ich's einmal geschafft hab. So oft sind Tauben auf der Strasse, selbst wenn man draufhält, was man ja auch so lernt in der Fahrschule, aber selbst wenn man draufhält, die blieben ja einfach. Ja, diese Biester. Ja, das ist tricky. Und die war doof anscheinend, die ist geblieben und dann … Oder Lebensmüde, suizidal, keinen Bock mehr. Vielleicht hatte sie eine Menschenphobie, vielleicht hättet ihr mal wirklich einen Dialog starten können, ihr beiden. Einen schönen Abend miteinander verbringen müssen. Ja, irgendwie einen netten Abend bei einem schönen Panino oder bei einem Lagos oder so. Ich weiß nicht, wenn ihr jetzt gar nicht wegfliegt, kommen, gehen wir ein Bier trinken. Ja, aber dabei habt ihr euch genau überfahren. Das ist echt traurig, ey. Scheiße. Man muss dazu sagen, dass Stefan heute das erste Mal in seinem Leben einen fucking Basecap falsch rumträgt und er hat irgendwie so einen Baseball-Shirt und er sieht aus wie so ein Jog. Ich wollte ihn gar nicht vorlassen, weil er einfach ein falsches Bild von uns beiden darstellt. Normaler ihn nicht zuerst begrüssen. Normalerweise sehen wir anders aus. Also ich sehe normalerweise, ich sehe schon ziemlich cool aus heute, sonst sehe ich nicht so cool aus. Also ich habe mir heute echt Mühe gegeben. Ja. Die Kappe, ich trage auch sonst eine Kappe, aber ich hätte auch keine Lust, meine Haare irgendwie Mühe zu geben. Und dann habe ich die einfach mit einer umgedrehten Kappe aufgesetzt, weil aber... Das hast du noch nie vorher gehabt. Nee, noch nicht. Ich bin zum ersten Mal eine Kappe, habe ich auch. Dann läuft er immer mit diesem Football durch die Gegend, er sieht wirklich aus wie so ein amerikanischer Jog. Wir haben uns überlegt, dass wir immer einen Football hin und her werfen. Ja. Ideen, einfach dass man sich quasi Ideen so wirft und dann nochmals mit und wenn er den fangen muss, eine Idee sagen zum Beispiel. Im fällt eigentlich nur noch dieser roter Plastikbecher, dann würde er direkt aussehen wie aus so einer Teenage-Komödie, einer amerikanischen Teenage-Komödie. Ja, ja doch, da sehe ich das Thema. Ich sehe immer auch neulich, einmal musste ich für so ein Video fürs Neo Magazin so ein Basketballanzug, ein komplettes Outfit anziehen. Basketballanzug? Nee, ein Basketballoutfit, wollte ich sagen. Du warst nicht als Basketball verkleidet. Nee, ich war, nein, nein, nein, aber das, ich verstehe doch, aber ein bisschen Basketballoutfit an. Ja. Und da sah ich auch aus wie jemand, der in einem Musical einen Basketballspieler darstellt. Ich sehe immer alles, was ich anziehe, aussieht wie ein Musicaldarsteller, der gerade versucht, so einen Fredboy darzustellen. Ich glaube, du wirst auch, wenn du Polizist wärst, würdest du immer aussehen wie ein Stripper. Ich sehe ihn aussehen wie ein Musicaldarsteller, der ein Polizistenspieler. Aber wie lustig ist das denn so? So ganz schemenhaft. Hey Stefan Stefan, hast du Bock heute Basketballspiel zu gehen? Ja klar, heute um drei, ich bin da und dann kommt er an und hat einen riesigen Basketballkostümen. Er hat schon wieder getan, wie damals beim Federball. Hey, ich dachte, ihr wollt Basketball, also alle tragen so ein Basketball. Ich spiele Basketball. Das ist schon nicht schlecht, ja. Oder ich bin der einzige, der nicht in dem Basketballkostüm kommt. Hätte man auch machen können, den Gag. Ruf für den Gag an, mit der Endnummer, Endziffer zwei. Entschuldigt euch, woran ist der bessere, dann mit der Endnummer eins. Ja. Ja, vielen Dank. Das ist toll, wir kriegen immer so kleine Einblicke in diese Leben, in verschiedene Tierwelten, in Ängste, in Phobien, in Träumen und Hoffnungen. Dagegen für ein wie einfach so langweilige Leben, Netflix und Masturbieren halt, aber... Ja, im Grunde 70-30. Cool, ja, vielen Dank, dass du da warst, Victoria. Cool, dass ich da war. Ja, immer gerne. Gerne. Und ansonsten … Wenn man dich irgendwo sehen will, kann man das tun? Ähm, im Moment bin ich ja jetzt gerade abgespielt und fahre in Urlaub, also ich spiele jetzt erstmal … Wo kann man mich im Urlaub sehen? Wo kann man mich im Urlaub sehen, in einem Pelz und dann einem Bikini-Alternativ?
Online, meine Webpage.
www.viktoriaklimack.de
www.viktoria-www
Und der Film ist jetzt auf Netflix, Victoria.
Könnt ihr euch anschauen? Und dem iTunes Store.
Ist der Film.
So, wir sind ja ein UFO, deswegen heben wir am Ende immer ab.
So, wir he ja ein UFO, deswegen heben wir am Ende immer ab. So, wir heben jetzt ab.